في هذه المنطقه منطقه ابو اسكندر حاول
الاهالي هنا اعاده الحياه مجددا وانشاء
سوق في المنطقه التي انسحبت منها الدبابات
الاسرائيليه الا ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي باغتت هؤلاء المواطنين
باستهداف منزل لعائله بركات ما ادى الى
ارتقاء ثمانيه شهداء جميعهم من المدنيين
وفي تعمد واضح من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه
لاعدام الحياه في هذه المناطق التي تنسحب
منها طيله ايام العدوان المستمر على قطاع
غزه
ثلاثه ونص تقريبا اسمعنا ل ه الصارخين
نزلوا في في الدار شقه اللي هو الطابق
العلوه والطابق السفله برض طبعا الطابقين
مسكونين يعني مسكونين عندك الطابق السفلي
اللي هو فيه عمي واولاده ثلاثه ونسوانهم
واولادهم اطفال يعني صغار واللي فوق تاع
برضه عمي اللي هو اولاده بس يعني شباب
طلعت من الباب طلعت من الباب لقيت غبرها
في وجهي خشيت على الدار المضروبه اللي هي
دار ابوي اي ضويت الضوء بطلع لقيت الدار
كلها دمار زي ما انت شايف كلها
دمار الحمد لله يعني ربنا يعوضنا عوض خير
توفت زوجتي استشهدت وثنين استشهدوا احنا
نايمين ما لقينا ال رادم الا فوقنا
والشهداء حتى فوقنا بقى احنا طلعناهم
بادينا وبم عافيه ب 100 عافيه لما انقذنا
حالنا رب العالم احنا في عننا مقاومين
وهذا فض المقاومه كله كم واحد ثمن شو هذا
عننا من ال بركات الله نا الساعه 3
وع سمعنا صوت ل جبات ع الشارع مخش صعين في
الكن طح الصوت اربعه ونص وخمسه
[موسيقى]
سيننا يعني فينا نايمين وفينا
صحيح صارت الدنيا ع نطلع على اولاد نطلع
نطلع هل قدرنا نطلع وطلعنا هلي ما قدرنا
نطلع ماطلعنا اطلعنا في النهايه في حصيله
اربعه
شباب لا ثلاث شباب و طفلين ونسوان اثنتين
ثمانيه ثمانيه منهم اسلام ومنهم اطفال
ومنهم شباب ومنهم نسان ثمان كبار منهم
شباب وعينه بركات حامل بركات حامل بركات
ابوي حامل بركات حسبنا الله وبتنعم الوكيل
عليهم
ماز ري